and The Godfather what Michael Corleone  wants to be initially is he wants to be  someone removed from the mafia right and  you see him wearing his army suit when  you first see him at the wedding and he  has his non-italian wife and he is the  Goody Two-Shoes guy is going to go be a  politician and that's what he's trying  to be and then throughout the movie  these chain of events cause him to be  who he actually is which is the next  Godfather and the final scene is his  wife going did you which was his  sister's husband for being a snitch he  goes no I didn't she goes did you he  goes fine ask me I'll tell you the truth  remember he was an honorable man an  upstanding man an army man right and  then she goes no I didn't know and she  knows that he lied and he lied and now  the character has fully switched he is  no longer The Honorable man he is the  mafia man that he was always trying